Greetings. I'm very pleased to
be here in CDW twenty one and
talk to you,
knowledgeable people,
about knowledge
and how we should
rethink it, restructure it,
and prepare it
for a better AI.
The last decade has
been phenomenal
for AI, primarily because of
deep learning.
But there's a next
wave that is coming.
And whether use system two
definition that Yoshua Bengio
is doing based on Kanban's or
use the DARPA definition of
the third wave of AI,
there's something
new that's coming.
AI that is more cognitive,
that has better understanding
of the world, that has higher
intelligence.
And this is going
to be done through
a combination
of components. It's going to
have neural networks in it.
It's going to have symbolic
representation and symbolic
reasoning in it.
And, of course,
it's going to be based on deep
knowledge. And
when we have it,
the value that is provided to
individuals, to businesses,
would be redefined and much
enhanced compared
to even the great
things that we can do today.
This will require
new architectures
to implement it,
which we'll talk
about later on.
And with all that
coming together,
a new human centric cognitive
AI is about to arrive.
I mentioned deep knowledge.
What do I mean by that?
If you look at the nature of
recognition versus
higher level
cognition, they are
very different.
In recognition,
there's a world out there with
relatively shallow data.
If you look at pixels,
you just have their
location, the color,
their intensity,
but the data is
relatively shallow.
It's continuous.
It's differentiable.
And you need deep learning and
other methods in order
to structure it,
find what is
the meaning of that,
and then make it
into knowledge.
Cognition is different.
High cognition requires to to
understand a very
deep structure
of knowledge.
Let's take the example,
is grandma well?
In order to pass
and understand
what is grandma,
what is this
particular grandma,
what is expected in
any particular age,
what's the history,
and many other things.
What is relatively
well for this
particular grandma.
There's so much
knowledge that's
in there that all comes forth
with a simple question.
So deep knowledge
are knowledge
constructs that allow an AI to
continuously acquire
new information,
organize its internal
view of the world,
comprehend the meaning
of grandma
and well in context and reason
on its knowledge.
Language models are great,
and they are able
to fill in word,
generate new statements,
and in them,
there's a lot of knowledge.
There's statistical
information,
of course. There's a lot of
factual knowledge,
and there even
some common sense
knowledge. And you can see it
in some of the benchmarks like
the natural questions
or trivia QA,
where models like t five that
were trained
through masking and
other methods are able to give
pretty good results.
And in addition to just having
those direct ways of assessing
how much knowledge
is in there,
you can enhance it.
For example, the work that was
done in Eugene Choi's group on
Atomic shows that
you can extract
from GPT three a lot
of common sense,
information and
enhance a knowledge
graph by ten x
from common sense
information that
is within a large
model, a GPT three.
And GPT three by itself,
by being prompted,
can give you some really nice
common sense answer
like x starts
running so x gets in
shape and so on.
So overall, it's good.
Language models
are one of option
for good knowledge models.
There's also some additional
value that has been quoted on
why there might be a very good
knowledge model because,
there's no schema
engineering,
there's no need to have preset
relations and also there's no
need for a person,
for humans to provide
supervision.
So, are language models great
knowledge models?
And the answer, I
believe, is not.
Language models are not great
knowledge models,
and it's true both on
the effectiveness,
which is how well
they perform,
as well as their efficiency,
which is how much
compute do you
need in order to perform.
And let's take the same t five
and the benchmarks
that we just show,
very good performance in.
When you integrate retrieval,
such as in RAM or RAG or more
recently infusion
and decoder,
you can get a much
better results
like going from
thirty six point
six to fifty one point four on
the actual f one or the exact
MET scores. And you can do it
with a much smaller model.
By using information,
in this case,
that resides outside
and effectively
bring it in, you improve both
efficiency and the quality of
the result. Well,
you're saying that language
models are
performing very well
as a repository of knowledge,
so what's the problem?
Well, they were
not designed for
that and even though
they do well,
we need to think about what is
really the optimal way of
representing knowledge.
And there are some
basic limitations
in the representation
and other
aspects that make
language model
good but not great
for the task.
And we should remember that
sometimes there's so much
information learned in those
language models that we can
extract and enhance dedicated
knowledge models.
But by themselves,
there are several
shortcomings,
and let's look at
what those are.
So what makes for a great
knowledge model?
I would say five areas
of capabilities,
scalability, fidelity,
adaptability,
richness, and explainability.
Let's talk a bit
about each of them.
The scale of information that
we're dealing with
is very high,
and you can see
that if you look
just at the sizes of
the recent models.
How do systems deal
with this tension?
On one hand, you want to have
the largest scale possible.
On the other hand,
you want expediency.
You want the ability to do it
in a very cost
effective manner.
There is a way
that systems deal
with that,
and that is by creating tiers
or a hierarchy.
You want to
differentiate between
things that you access every
tenth time to maybe items that
you access every ten
trillion times.
And by providing
this hierarchy
such as in a computer system,
you are able to
separate the closest
thing in the computer system.
It would be within
the registers
or the cache. Can be
easily accessible.
There's a small
scale, high cost,
but you get it
when you need it
immediately. And
then as you go
to further and further tiers,
you have a larger
scale, more capacity.
The speed is lower,
and the cost is lower.
So by having a full
hierarchy system,
you can have the scale
of the largest
tier, but you can do a much
shorter access time and better
cost than with a single tier.
And many systems in nature are
operating in the same manner.
Let's take an example
from a completely
different space.
Energy gets to our cells by
transforming ATP to ADP,
and it's just there.
How do we get this energy?
We get a glucose
circulating in
the bloodstream.
So there's lots
of energy going
around but still
needs a little
bit of processing to
become available.
But all this
glucose circulating
is not enough.
There's storage,
there's backup,
and that one is glycogen or
others that is
sitting in liver,
muscle cells, fatty tissue,
and can be turned
into glucose.
But there's the external,
the largest tier is of course
the outside world
where you have
all this energy that
can be consumed,
digested, and then turned.
So the idea of having a tiered
system is one that is in all
environments and settings,
which require
a huge scale with
very fast access.
Another area is
the richness of
knowledge. The
ability to capture
all the complexities,
all the relationship
in both in
the language world as well as
in other modalities.
And this is
something that I'm,
invited to read in a blog that
I published on the dimensions
of knowledge. But
just in a nutshell,
there's knowledge
about the world
that needs to be captured,
and it could be
descriptive like
taxonomies or
ontologies and and
property inheritance.
It could be either language or
it could be a three d point
cloud about some
some, assets,
some physical objects that you
capture inside.
The second is
ability to capture
models of the world.
Causal models,
procedural models,
physical models,
how things are
related and moving
in time, in space,
in progression.
And finally, scripts
and stories.
It's not just things
that are point.
There are complex
story that we
tell ourselves that we know
things about the world which
needs to be captured
in this form.
And then there's
the meta knowledge,
context, source attribution.
So if you read
something in a,
in a magazine from
the Newsstand
or you read it from the,
the New England Medical,
Journal of Medicine,
you will treat it differently
because you understand
the attribution
to the sources.
And then there's values and
priorities which
are so important
as part of our
knowledge structure.
When is something
more applicable?
What's the value
that we put on it?
And then finally, concepts.
Concepts are
the most important
construct that
we use as humans
to think and build
views of the world,
and concepts are the one that
cutting across
all those views.
The next area is
adaptability.
A knowledge model
must work with
multitude of data
sources, types,
and update rates.
So if I'm a dentist
with a small office,
I want to be able to work with
my patient's
information and be
able to update it quickly and
be able to have
different types
of information in there.
If I'm a financial
institution,
it's very different
types of data.
Also, the rate of change and
update of the model
is very important.
The model need to
change as fast
as the relevant
part in the world
changes. So if it's
about tracking
where people live and what's
their phone numbers,
that's one rate.
If it's tracking the latest
earthquake in California,
it's a different rate.
And there's no
path where going
through a retraining or even
fine tuning with new data can
refresh as quick as the world
changes in some
of those cases.
The next area is
explainability.
When an AI interacts
with humans,
how can the AI
explain itself,
be interpretable
and communicate
in a very natural manner?
And this is better structured
when you have an explicit,
intelligible source
of knowledge.
For one,
all the structure is built in
a way that is transparent.
Whether it's
a taxonomy or other
relationship, it
can be explained
more simply.
It also have all
the constructs
to do what if
analysis counterfactual
in a way that can
be mapped back
to this explicit structure.
And finally, it gives a better
foundation for a human AI
communication
where information
can be exchanged,
adopted, integrated,
and communicated back.
Finally, fidelity.
Knowledge models must retain
information in
a form that allows
faithful reproduction
to the origin,
whether it's facts,
attributes,
relationship. When you store
them in a knowledge graph,
you can store them
in a way that
is true to source.
You can also store
them in a way
that is not dependent
on statistical
occurrence. So
whether it happened
once or it happened
multiple times,
you are much less sensitive to
catastrophic
forgetting or other
types of decay.
And also because
you have the full
structure, because you
have the sources,
you can diminish
some of the effects
of training based bias.
We spoke about all
those principles
of having a great
knowledge model,
but how does it translate to
an actual
architecture that can
support the next wave of AI?
And I would posit that
the architectures
need to have knowledge and
information at three levels.
It can do more,
but three levels
is the necessary
and sufficient partition.
So I call it three levels
knowledge or it
sounds phonetically
like thrill k.
And the first level
is for the most
immediate knowledge,
and that knowledge is,
let's call it giga scale.
And it should sit in
the newer network.
The next level of knowledge is
the deep knowledge base.
So this could be
a knowledge graph,
for example. This is where you
have intelligible,
structured,
explicit knowledge.
And this one could
be at the terror
scale. And this is available
whenever is needed
by the neural
network. And finally,
there's the world
information.
And the world
knowledge or world
data is considered
to be zeta scale.
You've got things
today in terms
of the flow of
information that
are reaching that level of ten
to the twenty one.
And we need to plan our system
for the Yetta scale,
the ten to the power
of twenty four.
So we have those three levels
of knowledge, The immediate,
the one that is associated in
the knowledge base,
and the one that is supporting
out there in the world.
How do we put it together as
an architecture?
So how does the three
k architecture
look like? It has
those three elements.
It has the neural network with
a lot of knowledge within its
parametric memory,
and simple flows could just go
from input through
neural network
to output.
But it also has
the knowledge base,
structured, explicit,
intelligible knowledge base.
So when needed,
you can have
the extraction into
the neural network.
And I'm saying reason because
there's not only the symbolic
representation which
is in the deep
knowledge base,
but also the ability to do
symbolic reasoning.
And then,
since you cannot have
all the information
of the world inside your model
updated at the right rate,
there needs to be access to
the outside world
and all the corpus
of data, documents, images,
earthquake information,
financial,
everything that's
happening out
there based on
the application.
And there needs to
be the retrieval
mechanisms, obviously,
but there also needs
to be a knowledge
acquisition that continuously
updates an ever
growing consistent
view of the world
within the machine.
And this is how we can avoid
going to some of
the shortfalls
of handmade expert
systems of the past.
So how will this
new AI look like?
What is this new cognitive AI
that will emerge?
Well, you have to
imagine beyond
statistical correlation,
beyond the type of things that
we are very
impressed by today.
You need to imagine an AI that
actually understands language
by understanding concepts and
relationship,
not just predicts
the next word or
the next phrase.
You need to imagine an AI that
is inherently multi sourced so
it can converge
multiple sources
into its knowledge.
And multi model,
because the world around us is
multi model and rich.
It integrates common
sense knowledge,
and common sense knowledge is
the basis for making reasoned
intelligent decisions.
It can adapt to
new circumstances
and new tasks because the data
and the knowledge
is not structured
for a particular task,
but it's there with all its
richness and
expressivity to be
used for new tasks.
It explains itself
and communicates
better based on
what we discussed
earlier. And importantly,
it is more robust
and customizable.
For the long tail
of use for AI,
the AI needs to
adapt to particular
environments, to your car,
to your home so that it learns
the specifics,
it builds it into
its knowledge, and
it can interact
with you in
the most appropriate
way for you.
So those competencies together
create
a anthropocentric cognitive
AI that can be
achieved only if
we use knowledge underlying,
which is explicit,
intelligible,
and well structured.
So what is needed to make
cognitive AI a reality?
Well, it takes more
than a village.
It takes the whole
community to do it.
And some of
the things that are
required are the capabilities
to access and to mine diverse
sources of knowledge
and be able
to bring them into
the knowledge model.
We need to have
strong semantic
parsers and
knowledge representations
for all this
diverse multimodal
knowledge. We need to have
hardware and software that is
able to do all this,
hierarchically,
on the fly, in a cost
efficient manner.
We need to be
able to have some
apps that are
really showcasing
this to drive
the need and make
all the necessary improvements
on those workloads.
And finally, I expect to have
a new marketplace
created since
this is the age of
knowledge emerging.
Knowledge structure
or knowledge
basis can be sold,
communicated,
and used as other precious
resource that we have
around us today.
We are doing our part of this
within Interlapse
at my emergent
AI research organization.
We are looking at
multiple aspects
of this, including
NLP, multimodality,
common sense reasoning,
neuromorphic computing.
And this is just an example of
demonstrating
the match that is
being created between a word
being addressed
by the language
transformer, part of the image
that's corresponding,
and there's also
a data structure
that is mapped into that.
And this work is featured in
visual comic leaderboard and
other places.
Let's bring it all together.
So when is it going to happen
and how is it going
to look like?
I expect that it
will take about
the same duration
as deep learning
took if you compare
two thousand
twenty one to twenty eleven.
So this year, cognitive AI is
still a nascent technology.
By twenty twenty five,
I expect it to be already in
some commercial use.
And by the end of the decade,
I expect it to be a mainstay.
And Thrill k promises to be
the blueprint of
how it's going
to be implemented,
And it needs to bring together
new network with symbolic
representation
and with symbolic
reasoning. It needs to be able
to adapt and
discover information
from the outside
world so it has
a continuously growing
knowledge base.
It has to be able to provide
support at scale
to a diversity
of users as well
as usages through
its flexible
knowledge structure.
And it's gonna
build around deep
knowledge that is
conceptualized,
multimodal, ontology based,
and it's ready for
the unfolding future.
Thank you very much.